I mean my name is Tyler Worman and I'm a
senior here at Hillsdale College
studying politics and I'm from Anaheim
California our speaker tonight is dr.
Arne Larry P Arne is the 12th president
of Hillsdale College where he is also a
professor of history and politics he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in
government from the Claremont Graduate
School he also studied at Worcester
College Oxford University where he
served as director of research for Sir
Martin Gilbert the official biographer
of Winston Churchill from 1985 to 2000
he served as president of the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy he serves on
several boards of directors and he
previously served on the US Army War
College Board of Visitors for two years
for which he earned the Department of
the Army's outstanding civilian service
medal in 2015 he received the Bradley
prize from the Lynde and Harry Bradley
Foundation a member of numerous
organizations including the Churchill
Center he's the author of three books
Liberty and learning the evolution of
American education the founder ski the
divine and natural connection between
the Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it and most
recently Churchill's trial Winston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government please join me in welcoming
our president dr. Larry iron
hey what do you Thank You Tyler I just
asked Tyler a senior when he majors in
he said probably fix that I asked him
what that is and he doesn't know it's
actually a little harder to find if
you're a kid
good job Tyler's a fine young man very
smart I shouldn't make fun of them you
know in front of all you but that's what
I do for a living
thank you Andrew Minny Robert and
Richard who's all spoken beautifully
this week and I'm so proud to have them
here
thank you Doug and Tim and Matt for
organizing this conference and thank all
of you for being here Doug who orders me
about for a living has decided me to
talk about peace and Churchill so I'm
going to begin with a story about war
the reason I begin with this story is
that when I it's when I first learned
about Churchill and a lot of young
people here and they should learn it too
in 1977 I was a graduate student and I
was house-sitting for a man who had
written his doctoral thesis on Winston
Churchill in the house was full of
Churchill books and I had a very tough
boxer dog my first one by the name of
Thor aptly named and I had not yet met
penny and so there was no one to make
the dog sweet and so this dog was always
getting in dog fights which I was very
proud that he won I've learned better
than that now under the tutelage of my
wife but I was bitten by this dog I have
a scar right here I'll show it to you
after if you want to see it I like it a
lot because I was laid up my hand
swelled up will be
and I had stuff from the vet to treat
puncture wounds and dogs because this
dog was getting in dog fights and so I
just treated myself with that stuff and
I was laid up and there were these
Churchill books there and I started
reading them that was what I could reach
and I'm gonna read you the first
paragraph I ever read it was the custom
in the pommy days of Queen Victoria this
is the beginning of Churchill's world
crisis in my opinion his second greatest
book it's about the First World War it
was the custom in the palmy days of
Queen Victoria for statesmen to
expatiate upon the glories of the
British Empire and to rejoice in that
protecting Providence which had
preserved us through so many dangers
and brought us at last into a secure and
prosperous age little did they know that
the worst perils had still to be
encountered and that the greatest
triumphs were yet to be won who I
thought a drama Wow
then another surprise on the next page
Churchill the warrior the famous warrior
did not describe war as a march of glory
here's a passage the Great War through
which we have passed different from all
ancient wars in the immense power of the
combatants and they're fearful agencies
of destruction and from all modern wars
and the utter ruthlessness with which it
was fought all the horrors of the ages
were brought together and not only
armies but whole populations were thrust
into the midst of them nope truce our
parley mitigated the strife of the
armies the wounded died between the
lines the dead mouldered into the soil
merchant ships and neutral ships and
hospital ships were sunk on the seas and
all on board left to their fate are
killed as they swam every effort was
made to starve whole nations into
submission without regard to age or sex
cities and monuments were smashed by
artillery bombs from the air were cast
down indiscriminately poison gas in many
forms stifled or seared the soldiers
liquid fire was projected upon their
bodies when all was over torture and
cannibalism of the only to experience
that the civilized scientific and
Christian states had been unable to deny
themselves and these were of doubtful
utility now the first thing we need to
do is understand how remarkable this
passage is and I can do the unfair thing
of casting it in relief if you ever read
a book written by a politician
I mean the ones that they make millions
of dollars to write and somebody else
writes and nobody reads the travel logs
of Hillary Clinton the adventures and
Senate deals of Robert dole but this is
really unfair but I think I may know the
worst in history of the genre it would
be the memoirs of Mikhail Gorbachev
which actually contains this sentence
and I promise to all my colleagues in
the college that I'm not making it up
he's describing one of his own speeches
in his memoirs
I started off like Hamlet's famous
soliloquy now quote from the speech how
to deepen and make irreversible
revolutionary perestroika which on the
initiative and under the leadership of
the party has been launched in our
country this is the fundamental question
yeah now I'm going to give myself away
because of course I have not read this
book and neither has anyone else
but PJ O'Rourke has reviewed the book he
writes in response to this claim that
this speech was like Hamlet to which if
I remember my Shakespeare lophelia
replies sweet prince
take your Prozac I bet you money PJ
O'Rourke has never read that book
surely not but Churchill wrote that that
I just read he wrote 50 books like that
his speeches published over 8,000 single
spaced pages and we know of three or
four of those pages that he did not
write and they're all like that
can you write like that
can you write like that and fight in the
two greatest wars in history is a leader
can you write like that and go through
the Great Depression never been anybody
like that nobody ever did that except
him
people who write about him if they don't
absorb that obvious and first fact they
have not seen the forest only the trees
are apparent to them now I'm going to
interrupt my argument such as it is and
draw conclusions along the way I'm going
to draw four and this is the first one
the classics teach us that we all have
to meet our testing place to use a
phrase that I heard Steve Smith's pedia
say at convocation in action and through
faculty called prudence why do we need
this faculty what is it first of all we
all have principles don't we we're not
like the dogs certainly not like the
dogs that penny and I are owned by when
we do something we question it later and
before we do it we question it we have
these principles and they stand outside
what we do and they call what we do into
question and on the other hand we have
to do and we have to do amid
circumstances and what we do depends
very much on what the circumstances are
Churchill wrote in two beautiful places
in separate places one that there were
some things you could never do in war
ever like abandoned the Greeks when the
natsu and the Germans attacked him and
then in another place when he's writing
about the Duke of Marlborough a long
time ago he says circumstances alone
decide what is right to do in war and
the faculty that arbitrates between them
is this rational faculty called
practical judgment and we all need it
and it's all it's where we are every
difficult thing we do in our lives we do
use
that faculty and we find out what our
characters are and also we shape our
characters by that faculty here at the
college we are trying to teach these
young people about that specific thing
they have to understand the ultimates
that's the purpose of life but you
cannot understand them until you get
your character in such a places you can
attend to them and you do that by
passing these tests and the classic
article are authors who first wrote
about this said that the way to learn
this is to look at people who have the
reputation for great statesmanship
because that reputation is very rare not
many people can do it and so if you meet
somebody like that or learn of somebody
like that then you should read about him
because they're making the very hardest
choices life-and-death choices Churchill
gave a speech on the 28th of May 1940 in
war and Britain was about to quit the
war and respond favorably to a Peace
Conference proposal from Mussolini and
he walked in the room he was the Prime
Minister there wasn't anybody else who
came in the room who would be even
inclined to say what he said and he said
after talking impromptu for an hour I've
been thinking in these last few days
whether it is my duty to open
negotiations with that man meaning
Hitler and I believe that if ever for a
moment to consider parley or surrender
every one of you would rise up and tear
me down from my place if this island
story is to end at last let it in with
each of us lies choking in his own blood
upon the ground
amazing thing to say and he turned the
room around and he turned the world
around there are people today who blamed
him for that speech there wasn't anybody
else in that room who could've made that
speech or was wishing to make him it was
an act of prudence and it was prudence
because did you read that passage as you
hear that passage I read the first thing
I learned about this great man after I
learned why can he not write I'm going
to read more of that
I find that was 40 some years ago and I
still do the second thing I learned was
he was afraid of war offended by it
thought that it had changed in scope and
he names the two ways in this passage
how it changed the first was we have
discovered somehow or recovered somehow
the ruthlessness that happened in the
ancient world when whole cities would be
destroyed by for example the last time
Alexander of Thebes when all of the men
were killed and the women and children
were sold into slavery we're doing
things like that again except the
difference now is we have powers that
they did not have we can destroy a whole
countries we can put whole populations
to war now the battles have involved
millions of people it's possible he
writes in 1925 in an essay called shall
we all commit suicide mankind has never
been in this position before without
having improved appreciably in virtue or
enjoying wiser guidance he's got into
his hands at last the means of his own
destruction
that's 1925
it's 1940 when he says every one of us
in this room is to fight and yet he was
afraid of the fighting don't you see
what a rich problem of that racist
that's huge how are we conduct to
conduct ourselves in a world or
civilization and the freedom upon which
it lies understand Churchill is
systematic about this point civilization
just really means civil like the Roman
Latin word right the things of the
citizen it means the rule of law and if
you have that then freedom will grow and
from freedom will grow all of the
greatnesses that we study here in this
College and the job is to protect that
and war can destroy it all but so can
Hitler so what if you get yourself in a
place where you got a pick
the other he got in that place and he
said before he got there I felt as if I
were watching walking with the destiny
and all my life had been but a
preparation for this hour and this trial
I went to sleep and slept soundly
without dreams because sometimes facts
are better than dreams do you see he
wanted to be there but he took it
seriously it wasn't like I just want the
power
I want the test I want to see if I can
help to prove that human beings are
capable of living well even in this
dangerous age so then if my first
conclusion is we who wish to guide our
lives well wish to study a classic
example of it here's one my second is
Churchill was afraid of war all his life
from 1898 on I said the reasons we are
the same being as we used to be but we
are massively more powerful now and
think what what hell we can let loose I
was saying to somebody the other day
technology doesn't matter in war it was
last semester actually it was mr.
danfous of the graduate school what if
he's here tonight
idiot boy and he was saying it doesn't
change anything and I said no nothing at
all it's September 11th 2001
and almost a dozen guys have trained
like crazy and they said to make their
assault on Manhattan and they're
carrying the weapons of the day and the
weapons of the day are clubs or bows and
arrows would we remember September 11th
2001
Churchill figured that out
my third conclusion is that now talk
about peace because come to find out
it's the same thing
Churchill thought that this attitude
could see there's two things going on
one is the power of Natural Science
Churchill loved that one of his best
friends was a physicist named Frederick
Lindemann whom he made appear and who
was a very powerful man in the Second
World War and that tells you something
right because there are two things about
Lindemann and Churchill the first one is
they needed a bunch of very powerful
weapons to work so they could kill the
Nazis because the Nazis were working on
the same weapons and Lindemann helped
make that possible so science was
important because you had to have it you
can't give it up and yet it's dangerous
but then the second point is even in a
way more powerful and that is he just
loved this guy Lindemann because
Lindemann could explain the world to him
modern science is a way of the holding
that is awesome than what it can show if
you want the best two examples I've ever
seen on this campus they are etched in
my memory and I will never forget them
and you can go to our website tonight
and watch them both they're both
convocation speeches one is by the
physicist Ken Hayes and one is by the
chemist Chris Van Orman and there are
seen and they just explain to you
magical things that we have discovered
about the universe that were unknown to
the ancients in all their greatness a
new and powerful way of beholding
Churchill knew that and he loved that
but then there's this other thing about
science that it does give all this power
and it is accompanied by a different
kind of philosophic doctrine that is
very prevalent and not the doctrine that
you will hear from professors Hayes in
Van Orman and that doctrine is we have
come into our own at last and we can
conquer everything and we have the tools
of science
do it and we can make the world however
we want it to be and if you just think
through that claim for a minute and that
claim read the paper tomorrow and you
will see some powerful person making
just that claim they'll make it about
the environment or they'll make it about
that family or they'll make it about
income stratification but they'll make
it about war or they make it about the
thousand pressing topics the drought and
always it's true that whatever there
were were the rules about those things
in the past we can repeal those rules by
the power of science and that means that
a new kind of administration was born in
Churchill's
lifetime and it's the scientific beer
credit way the standards of which our
experimentation on the society the
Socialist Party comes in to Great
Britain in the British Parliament wins
its first seats in the year 1900 guess
what year Winston Churchill was elected
to Parliament for the first time and you
know here's something for you young
people when Churchill was 26 years old
he had fought in four Wars one of me
really only observed he distinguished
himself in all of them
everyone what I mean by distinguished is
he got mentioned and two of them in the
dispatches but also people their
soldiers recorded that they looked at
him and they went wow what's that guy
that guy's something in me
he was deliberate on a battlefield and
he did it on purpose so there are some
records to show so people would notice
him anything to get elected to
Parliament but then you know he
published what so three books two of
them bestsellers and he was one of the
most widely published and best-known
authors in England but by 26 and then he
got elected to Parliament as a war hero
he was crazy but in this novel that he
wrote in 1898
language one always remembers the dates
and then harrumphs because I don't
that's why that's why we're important
here right you do the dates Richard and
and he and he writes in this novel the
novel is a romance
it's called several uh you should read
it because it's an autobiography and
there's this Republican leader a man of
freedom named civ rola and of course
that's Weston Churchill and there's this
despot named olara and the despot
married to a beautiful woman named
Lucille light and come to find out
whoever gives the state is going to get
the girl
Melora is unworthy of her you eat Lit
majors will understand this if heels no
college students don't understand this
and their shame on them they have a
conversation around dinner time like the
editor of my book tried to make me take
that out and I referred him to the
English department what I'm about to
tell you and they're having this dinner
and the despot says beauty is in the
eyes of the beholder whatever you think
it is that's what it is and his wife
Lucille the beautiful Lucille intervenes
and says oh wait though aren't there
like some people who are very beautiful
and her husband in a stupid insult to
this beautiful woman it says no just
what we think right fashion is all shows
he's unworthy ever but also think of the
power that he's considering to hold over
nature that he becomes the standard by
which things like beauty are defined no
more looking up at something awesome and
wishing to serve it for the greatness it
contains and this boy Winston Churchill
writing this novel has the hero
intervene and says okay fashion is
something but look at that statue over
there any points at a replica of a Greek
statue he says for 2,000 years we have
called that beautiful doesn't that
indicate something more serious
there's a third contestant for the girl
it's a socialist whose name is belt Karl
with the king and they go to a speech by
the Cibola he's a very great speaker of
course and and he is walking out Lucille
is their hooded to hear the speech she's
already being wooed by several and she
overhears the socialist and he says he's
a good tool but what does he understand
of the community of property and then
his comrade who's that are killed at the
end of the novel says or the community
of wives I'd like to have the
president's wife and she shudders you
see there's three kinds of regimes and
there's three people who might get the
girl and one kind the power of the
leader is all in one kind every good
thing is shared equally among everybody
in the third kind their families and
property and limited rule and
representative government that's the
drama later Churchill repeats this theme
in his early speeches against socialism
and sure enough you know the Socialists
come into power what do they say in 1876
the Fabian essays are published by
George Bernard Shaw and Sidney Webb and
the people who started the favouring
movement and I think I say in my book
that that that book is authoritative
about the early British socialism in the
way the Federalist Papers are for
America for the Constitution and what
did they say in there they knew Karl
Marx he lived in London for a long time
and many of them knew him and Karl Marx
said you have to abolish this family
there via he was violently against it
because the women and children in the
family are the wage slaves of the wage
slaves but the Fabian say in the
beginning no no we're not for that at
all but then they talk about it quite a
bit as the essays go on and they say for
example it's very inefficient for small
groups to have dining
inside their own homes and they say that
we have to lay the economic basis so
everybody man woman and child has the
same income and if you think about it
for a minute that's a fact isn't it like
I'm very proud of my upbringing I'm
married penny you know who comes from a
very old family in England and so I'm
proud of that
after all I wonder but and her people
are very noble right whereas on my side
we're a bunch of mongrels we don't know
where we came from there's even some
prospect we used to be Jews we think
that would be cool because it's kind of
exotic and you know a little town in
Arkansas but I had this great gift see
my dad was a school teacher and there
were books around and people read them a
lot of people don't get that advantage
and how's that evil I didn't do anything
to deserve that other people are born
rich some are born without parents are
we ever really gonna equalize the
society until we get rid of the family
which by the way right now we are
bidding fair to do isn't the society
always to be unequal in the start of the
race of life until you do that and
equalize property to in fact don't the
same things good the two things go
together tempted to say as a man and
wife
that's what Churchill thought and he was
driven to a conclusion about that if you
do that
then the people who raise the kids are
gonna own them whereas parents don't own
them they own us the motive when we
raise them is love tonight one of mine
called and had a crisis and I said Lord
boy I'm busy today I had to go to
Pittsburgh and I got to give a big talk
to that can't you have this crisis
tomorrow
and his response was no I need you
tonight I said okay what is it right you
know anybody else called except one of
our other children and my wife and I
would have said shut up
talk tomorrow they own us but in this
other way you know if we were gonna
raise them all the same it would be a
different spirit behind their raising
but you could more commonly get it done
and if you're not gonna do that then the
society is going to be to some extent
unfair Churchill knew that and when you
read his arguments about socialism they
are deep and they are aware that if we
stick with the free market system and
limited government we're not going to
perfect the society it's just that
they're gonna make it worse subhuman
because the sources of inequality in us
are stubborn and they have their effect
even in an open society where the free
market works and where government is
limited and where people can have the
best chance to rise and there's the most
mobility he was on to that when he was
26 years old and he never lost it
see what else I have for conclusions
third conclusion is that this war became
virulent in Churchill's time as has
never been seen before you forget it but
politics did too this is the age of
totalitarianism
it's a latest form is in the Islamic
countries there you know did you read
when our conquest may be temporary
conquest of liberation of Afghanistan
one of the most telling testimonies was
a young man whose family had been held
hostage by the Taliban and his job was
to walk in the daytime among the people
looking for people who had their beards
the wrong length their their coats the
wrong length and at night walk among the
neighborhoods and listen for sounds of
music playing or television or card play
and he would report them and then they'd
be hauled off to the pokey they tortured
because they were revolutionizes society
see well what happened in the Soviet
Union what happened in Nazi Germany what
was it like what it was like was you
were afraid of your own children because
you were not in charge of their
education and in their schools they were
taught to turn on you and turn you in
and that means in your conversations
with your wife at the dinner table you
had to mind your tongue and the body
counts were in the tens of millions
hundreds of millions under communism
worldwide and Churchill saw that watched
it grow feared it and thought something
very radical because you know it's odd
if you go back through the history of
the 20th century to find a statesman who
was equally appalled by the totalitarian
of the right and the
Taron ism of the left and Churchill was
he once said they differ as the North
Pole differs from the south and if you
think about it those two places are very
far apart but you can't tell the
difference when you're there but then he
also said this thing see because analyse
what he meant by socialism what if what
he thought socialism meant in other
words to get the perfect quality that
they're after the central things about
human nature had to be expunged and some
other standards which we contrived
replacing it and Churchill said so I'll
tell you we said things like this all
his life and today historians write
about this dramatic one I'm going to
tell you about as if it's like a one-off
thing but he said it many times
including both before and after this and
sometimes just decades before in 1945 in
the 1945 election Churchill had become
something he'd never been he was the
greatest man in the world the way
everybody talked to him you know look
what he done you know and those speeches
that he gave they were just awesome and
he'd stuck it out in 1940 and he had
enormous prestige and he never lost him
and so The Times of London wrote it as
an editorial a leading article and they
said that what he should do is he should
be the elder statesman now and rise
above party politics and just lead the
country sort of above the party
continent party differences so here's
what he did instead he gave a speech
about socialism and see he's the man now
right he said the socialist party could
not realize its ultimate aims without
the use of a secret police yes I mean a
Gestapo now these guys in the Socialist
Party had been his wartime comrades and
the leaders among them including
especially Clement Attlee had tremendous
World War one fighting records they were
patriotic people and he says in there
they would not mean that horrified by
the idea of it but these principles you
see that's where they're going to go and
that means that all these fears that he
had of war it's not just true that
they're equal to the fears he had about
the direction of peacetime politics and
not just in the totalitarian countries
but the principles being similar in the
free countries they would eventually
lead thereto and that means by the way
that once the Churchill lived his whole
life thinking like that and yet it's all
about him because he was cheerful and
hilarious and determined brave and
eloquent and extremely productive year
by year by year by year for over 50
years
these forces are so huge and you know
once you figure out that he identified
them in the turn of the century and
arrived about 1900 a little before and
then you look about the world you today
he got beat in big ways looks like he
failed and you could think that it's
hopeless couldn't you
but how could well close with these two
points the first one is he thought he
knew what to do about it there's a
thought he knew what to do and he
thought he knew why that was bound to be
doable sooner or later what to do if you
think about it for a minute if war is
getting out of a kit hand then the print
then the solution is strategy which just
means you know it comes from a Greek
word that means a big area but it's also
the word for a general and it means
having a plan to prevent war if possible
and control its effects to the maximum
extent possible if you go read his iron
curtain speech in Fulton Missouri in
1946 you'll see what I regard is
the most brilliant articulation of a
strategy for the nuclear age anybody has
ever given is awesome but there would
need to be some parallel in peace when
there some way to go about approaching
politics in this age where scientific
administration is growing very fast and
the idea is that people can be altered
fundamentally and that becomes a purpose
of the government see and his idea about
that was constitutionalism he had a big
plan what did he think it was like what
he thought was those are big rules to
which people are loyal and they last a
long time and they both empower the
government because the government needs
to have a lot of power but also they
restrain it and how did they restraint
it and here's the really amazing thing
about him and he said by the way it's
also amazing that this guy who found all
these wars in his famous forms he
thought about this all his life and he
wrote a lot about it and what he thought
was the first element of
constitutionalism is we pick the
government and you see how that requires
a constitution because in Hitler
you know that's what Hitler demanded
it's why he got asked to be Chancellor
of Germany three times before accepting
because he had a condition I won't do it
unless we waive the Constitution I can
do whatever I want and if one person is
going to run everything then you don't
need any rules but if everybody's going
to be involved then there have to be
forms or patterns by which they do it
representative government requires
constitutionalism what's going on in the
world today the forums don't matter they
just do what they want
Churchill was afraid of that but then
the second thing is power needs to be
divided the progressives of Churchill's
time the fathers of the politics that we
have today in America they love the
British constitution because they
thought it set up a unified government
without checks and balances or
separation of powers Churchill disagreed
with that vile
in fact he thought the House of Commons
although it is the place that picks the
executive and the executive branch
senior leaders are members of the House
of Commons that's the place where we
control them because we're right there
with them and we're debating them every
week and we can watch everything we do
and then you know Churchill proposed
reforms to the British government which
would make it more like ours he proposed
federalism he proposed bicameralism he
wanted to make the House of Lords into a
body exactly like our Senate originally
was except picked by the members of the
House of Commons so indirectly elected
by the people he wanted to make the
government with more checks and balances
in it just like ours and you see if this
guy who has a hundred year record of
seeing these trends and war and peace
and that's what he came up with and then
the people a hundred and fifty years
before him in America that's what they
came up with
I'm just saying aw shucks there might be
something to it I'll close with this why
did Churchill think that Hitler could be
beaten in 1940 did you know in 1940 the
British were alone they had six or eight
divisions the Germans had hundreds they
had air superiority Britain had a bigger
Navy but it looked like the Air Force
was what really mattered as it proved it
was why didn't he and you know when you
were around him in 1940 he didn't
particular he said we're gonna go to
Berlin and we're gonna kill him
he needs killing and we're appointed to
do it we're gonna go do that thing and
you know they did why did he think that
was possible why did he think that these
waves
of government strengthening an awesome
authority that had been going on now
since before his time and continued to
pace today why did you think that could
be stopped
well come to find out like everything
else about him he explained he was
always writing stuff down
thread a book the other day he wrote in
1931 this is the year in which brave new
world was published although we know
that he didn't read that book because he
wrote a letter to his wife about it when
he did read it until 1958 he said that
we're going to get the power to make
people in laboratories and we can make
them either better or worse we can breed
them as it were so that they're good for
thought or they're good for toil just
like brave new world in April last year
two Nobel prize-winning biologist said
that we should have a moratorium in the
Wall Street Journal editorial on
changing the germline DNA because once
we change it human nature will be an
artifact they say something we make and
just as we can remove some birth defects
it looks like now and then more later no
reason why we couldn't improve what's
there and if we could improve what's
there no reason why we couldn't diminish
what's there and then you know all these
problems of inequality that are so
stubborn maybe they could be diminished
by people being happier with their
station but the trouble with that is we
would start looking at each other like
something we made a silly boy who called
me tonight I don't know what I look at
him like but I don't look like I don't
look at him like something I made he's I
don't know who made him buddy whoever it
was gave him to me and he's okay right
and he's mine he owns me that's what
that means
Churchill said that along with that
development then we could make a race
that new pleasures all the time that are
beyond anything any of us has ever
experienced and we could live as long as
we want and living as long as we want we
could go anywhere we want to go
including interplanetary he's describing
that we could live like gods I'll tell
you what he said about that but before I
do I'll just take this there was an
exact partner to that because in 1932 he
wrote a book called an essay called mass
effects in modern life and in that essay
he wrote the gloomiest paragraph he ever
wrote he says that the Russian
Bolsheviks would reduce us he says to
the to the situation of the white pants
in other words it's a rule that will
treat people like insects and he says
that's only an extreme form of the
doctrines that we have in the Western
countries do you get the impression that
this is a really thoughtful guy for a
politician because I'm telling you I
assert that these themes are consistent
right through his life
it's very extraordinary and then he says
in the next paragraph one of the most
hopeful things he ever says but you know
he says human nature is not as tractable
as Antin nature it is at once the glory
and the safeguard of mankind that it is
easy to lead and hard to drive in 2000
when rudbeck and his guys came to see me
about coming to work here somebody said
to me how did you learn about management
and I said well it doesn't count Peter
Drucker was my landlord they were all
very impressed with that I actually knew
him very well although I never studied
with him and I said what did count was
I've made a lot of mistakes and I tried
to make him twice and also I studied
Winston Churchill and mr. Pearson one of
them said what did you learn from him
and I said easy to lead and hard to
drive Churchill thought that I'm gonna
go away and you know what he thought
about this
perfect society where we could all live
as long as we want
have all the pleasure we want and have
all the servants we want and the
servants all be happy to serve us all we
want and even if we got picked to be in
the servant class we would be content
like cows that's the image and that's
possible
except for this she says what was the
good of all that to them what do they
know more than we know about the answers
to the simple questions which man has
asked since the earliest dawn of reason
why are we here what is the purpose of
life whither are we going no material
progress even though it takes shapes we
cannot now conceive well however it may
expand the faculties of man can bring
comfort to his soul it is this fact more
wonderful than any science can reveal
which gives the best hope that all will
be well
in other words when what's the Churchill
fought those Wars at home and abroad he
was fighting for a being that he thought
was built by God to be free and that no
active man could have faced that you
should study him thank you
immediately following this session dr.
Arne has agreed to sign copies of his
new book
Churchill's trial on the other side of
this curtain we now have time for a few
questions that books not very good but
you can have a signed copy and also I
should announce it's a mister slants
told me that it's in the top ten in all
categories on Amazon and so I hasten to
point out that any money I'm paid for
that book will come to the college
I expect to be arrested because of that
by the Internal Revenue Service yes sir
you characterized Churchill's the world
crisis as his second greatest book what
do you regard as his greatest Marber all
his life in times they're all good but
that's about an ancestor the greatest
English journal general and it contains
this passage he's describing how you
understand soldiers so all that stuff
about prudence that I said come to find
out Churchill was very thoughtful about
that he wrote a lot about it and it
tends to be beautiful and about that
he's describing how these generals are
really good and we underestimate them or
we miss estimate them because we don't
see what the problem is he says it's
actually pretty simple what can happen
in a war if you're a general you don't
actually have very many options right
you can stay where you are you can
retrieve you can go to either side or
you can advance and so whichever one he
picks if he loses then everybody writes
up how silly that was he should have
picked the other one that's what you
know if you read that's that's what war
stories read like unless by the way
they're written by Tom Connor is that
I've heard him tell many and he's got a
book coming out but he knows better than
ever so so Churchill says in fact they
have to decide at the time in the face
not just of the qualitative information
but the quantities and they're shifting
all the time how many are here how far
is that how much weight is this and it's
always changing and then he says nothing
but genius the diamond and man can
answer the riddles of war and because
genius is much rarer than the rarest and
purest of diamonds wars are mainly tales
of muddle so the book that that's in
because that's when it's in Churchill's
best best explanation I argue of himself
and also the answer I give people when
they ask me why isn't there Winston
Churchill around
the answer is there almost no prints but
there is one we can read about yes
Reverend good evening dr. Arnn
the CCA we've concentrated on Winston
Churchill's first prime ministership
I was wondering if you could comment on
his second one at that time Britain had
turned to socialism and Churchill was
Prime Minister a second time at a
crucial point in Britain's history I was
just wondering if you could comment on
the political struggles of that time and
whether you believe Winston Churchill
was successful in his confrontation with
socialists in Britain that's Josiah back
there
he's a show pony so he does an excellent
interpretation of Barack Obama you
should ask him to do it so the answer is
he won in 1951 and he didn't serve very
long and he was old by that time and he
had a very thin majority so what they
did do was D nationalize the steel
industry which he promised to do and not
the others more interesting about the
domestic policy questions are how he ran
the campaigns and the theme of both of
them was socialism versus the people and
he made the case that that what they're
going to do he said that one of the
things he said is they've actually
appointed a bureaucracy that forms an
army larger than any peacetime
bureaucracy army any peacetime army
Britain has ever had and he counted up
the numbers he's starting to make a
point that sometimes he said one number
and sometimes another but his idea was
this is all aim did you see and and is
and even explained and see that's you
know what do I think politicians ought
to do today I think they ought to do
exactly this I think they should make
the point that if you believe it and I
happen to
that there's some danger that the
government is going to overwhelm the
people then you will find hidden
speeches how to explain that and he did
win with that argument
my kids are asking questions thank you
for a good synopsis dr. Arnn in
Churchill's views post-war and how the
society was developing along with
mankind's traits and I was reminded it
seemed to be a parallel there between
what Churchill was saying as well as
some of the early artists a whija-- seen
a silent film by Fritz Lang in the early
Germany metropolis and it was exposing
this very same fear that without
internal moral guidance that mankind
could destroy itself do you see many
parallels between Churchill and the arts
of the time oh yeah he did too
so he liked that movie he liked movies
in general but he liked that movie and
he watched movies all the time it's
advice to cultivate but try to find good
ones and and he liked poems and he liked
novels and he liked and knew several of
the best poets who wrote poems
especially about the first world war
after the Second World War he was very
old but after the first world war RC
sheriff and went to his play called
journey's end in that right Richard
Darcy sheriff wrote that play and and he
knew him and that was a guy who fought
in the trenches and so the
dehumanization of war was a great theme
with Churchill now Churchill was no
Churchill was a painter and a good
painter in my opinion there are two
things in the world that I want that I
can't afford and one of them is one of
Churchill's paintings belongs to Brad
Pitt right now but and you know he's
richer than I am
but he liked bright vivid paintings and
he liked you know he couldn't match the
Masters but he did the Impressionists
and so the start nihilistic paintings of
more modern times he didn't like those
but he saw that he saw the point and
that it's it's worth making the point by
the way what is the claim the claim is
this here's the story of human history
in the modern account long time ago
there were these weak little beings
without much hair on them and they
weren't very fast and it's a miracle
they survived it's just that they were
great controverse and so they invented
tools and they used them and they go
watch the beginning of the movie 2001
for example God is the thing that brings
us technology and then they start
conquering nature and they conquer and
conquer and conquer until now they're
getting to the place where they can even
conquer nature in themselves and we have
to turn and see it wasn't scientist you
know natural scientist who made this
argument it was social scientists a new
discipline invented to mimic the natural
sciences and this point was we have to
use the tools of natural science to
govern human society because then we can
get to work on it and we can perfect it
and that's what Churchill saw and also I
should tell you he's not alone in that
Churchill had a contemporary in CS Lewis
and we study around here a lot a lot of
us do Churchill offered him a CBE and he
turned it down with the charming letter
and there are two other letters he wrote
in which he mentions the letter the
elections in 50 and 51 where Churchill's
running against the Socialists and he's
explicit that he's pulling to turn the
socialist down but Lewis's point
especially in his essay abolished a man
and in his novel which he says is
written along the same things that
hideous strength his point is that the
power
of man over nature is only expressed as
the power of some men over others so
that's what's going on in the world and
you're right it's reflected in art and
Churchill summit although he didn't put
it in in his own paintings we have time
for one more question yeah who are you
to be deciding that my name is Chris
prudence and Stefan Stefan here and I
were talking and we were wondering if
you could comment on how differently the
onset of the Cold War might have looked
had Churchill taken and I had the world
taken Churchill's distrust of Stalin
more seriously thank you well the
decision points there were in 1943 and
44 and in general there was a big
strategic argument among the Americans
of Roosevelt and his team and Churchill
and his team and on several key
occasions Churchill wanted the British
and American forces to thrust farther
east through the Mediterranean and they
wanted to take as much ground as far
east and north as possible from Italy
inwards and he definitely had in mind
the idea that that would prevent Stalin
from having so much
it wasn't the only idea Churchill was in
favor of the of the invasion through
France to northern France he was very
much against the second Western invasion
that happened through Marseille and they
came to words over that and there were
two times that I know of that we're
doing these documentaries now so I
probably would know but there are two
times that I know of when Churchill came
to very candid words about this and one
of them was in 1943 when Stalin was
informed that there wouldn't be a second
fry
that year and he really lame bested lamb
basted Churchill and Roosevelt for that
and Churchill got cranky about it
and he said of course they want us to
put all our forces in northern France
such a distance from all that territory
they're taking in Eastern Europe so you
can see that's on his mind right and
then in 1944 when they did do the
Marseilles invasion and he fought hard
against that and he that was the hardest
bitterest most vehement I guess you'd
say argument he had with Roosevelt and I
don't want to exaggerate how much he and
Roosevelt differed they did differ a lot
about these subjects and toward the end
Roosevelt sort of petered out you know
he was very ill and he died in 1945 and
and so he he wasn't a factor but
Churchill says I lodge a solemn protest
about this decision and then darned if
he didn't up and fly himself to Moscow
and make a deal with Stalin without
Roosevelt and it's a very dramatic
meeting it's called it's famous it's
called the percentages deal and and it's
a I think it is very clear what
Churchill was up to Churchill would go
over and see Stalin and they both stayed
up late date night and they both drank a
lot
although Stalin during more than
Churchill and it's a myth that Turner
was drunk hardly ever hated it I don't
know I actually think he probably was
never drunk but for sure
very seldom but they drank and talked
and Churchill would make big toasts and
bawl like a baby about the future easy
called himself a blubber baby about the
future of the Russian and the British
and the American people's right and then
this one is all different because they
sit across the table and there's a
British note note taker a major sitting
at the table taking notes and their
translators in the room and Churchill
says I've brought this document and the
song says yes he says it's a naughty
document I think we should destroy this
document
I'm going to show it to you and Stalin
now Stella is a great conspirator right
true solidus never talked to him like
that didn't talk to people like that in
general and what it is is it it says in
the land that's taken liberated by the
Allies east and west who gets what
percentage authority over what country
and there's one country that Britain can
get to on its own with its Navy not
needing any landing craft and that's
Greece and Britain gets 90 percent
authority in Greece and then they're
leaving the meeting is breaking up but
it's Stalin says at one point shouldn't
we have Averill Harriman the American
ambassadors come with Churchill from
London in these meetings and Churchill
replies and see this is a very unusual
thing for Churchill Churchill replies
well he should be in many of our
meetings but we have something to talk
about in this meeting I don't know that
we could tell the Americans about this
he says the Americans he's just
quarrelled with about where this next
front will be so so Churchill says to
him man I'm going down to Athens now and
Stalin says good and he says somebody
should talk to those people down there
and this Don says well I don't know that
one Churchill says to somebody should
and son says well maybe I could get them
a message and Churchill says you might
hurry and he goes down to Athens and you
know what happened in the battle was
that the Capitol was surrounded by
communist forces and they were
interrupted when they were near taking
the whole capital by a British Army that
came in there so I think he was thinking
about that in the post-war world and I
think he had very distinct views about
it he didn't like communism and I think
he was right not to I don't I don't
think by the way that the differences in
the United States Tom Connor will
probably know more
this than I do I don't think his
differences with the United States were
chiefly I don't know what that means I
know that that there are causes of the
United States looking at this
differently than just that they were
more tolerant or they liked communism
better than Churchill did although Alger
Hiss was a senior American official that
that's true but there was another thing
too and George Marshall said things like
this if you're sitting in Washington DC
the world looks different than if you're
sitting in London and so from his point
of view we've got to get to Berlin and
if you draw a straight line from us to
Berlin it goes right through northern
France we should go that way and
Churchill's idea was very different than
that and I think more sophisticated than
that but they thought too sophisticated
and so there's a real argument in the
middle of this not just an ideological
difference Thanks
the other side of the curtain thank you